hi everyone I'm Lucas Davis design  director at battlecry Studios battle cry  is an online action game with team based  combat and intense tactical warfare  faced off against opponents in the war  zones and battle for the glory of your  nation select players in Australia and  New Zealand have already joined us in  our alpha and soon the rest of the world  can join them in battle tonight we are  pleased to announce that we are  accepting worldwide signups for battle  cries global beta at battle cry the game  calm and sign up now before june  eighteenth and you'll receive priority  beta access as well as a special in-game  reward we look forward to seeing you in  the war zone this fall until then here's  a look at how battle cries evolved over  the last year and a sneak peek at our  brand new warrior faction DeHaan  republic  you  you